y me acabo de dar cuenta que no he
respondido a la pregunta que
probablemente se encuentre en sus mentes
después de haber visto el vídeo de
pólizas de seguro de vida a plazos y
completas ya que la opción completa
hablamos de este escenario en donde si
pagamos esta prima durante toda nuestra
vida todo el tiempo hasta el momento de
nuestro fallecimiento cuando fallece mos
nuestra familia va a recibir esta
cantidad como beneficio recibirá los 500
mil en el momento de la muerte
y también vimos el escenario que en
cualquier momento antes de esto y
decimos que bueno no necesitamos seguro
de vida se puede dejar de pagar la prima
la familia no recibirá el beneficio por
fallecimiento pero ustedes recibirán la
cantidad que se encuentre en la cuenta
de ahorros generada por la compañía de
seguros claro después de haber pagado
todas las cuotas de esa compañía de
seguros pero la pregunta que ustedes me
podrían hacer es al morir qué sucede con
lo que se encuentra en la cuenta de
ahorros porque antes de morir podemos
sacar lo que se encuentre en esta cuenta
de ahorros cuando ofrecemos nuestros
beneficiarios recibirán esta cantidad
pero qué sucede con lo que está en esta
cuenta de ahorros y la respuesta es que
no se obtiene esta cantidad se pierde
podríamos decir que es algo que está
respaldando el beneficio por
fallecimiento y algo que es
desafortunado si por cualquier razón
esta cantidad de efectivo es mucho mayor
que la cantidad asegurada no sé a lo
mejor ustedes viven una cantidad inusual
de años
con más de 50 años desde que contrataron
este seguro a lo mejor llegaron a los 90
años y durante todo ese tiempo ustedes
pagaron un total de 250 mil dólares
aunque recuerden que tenemos el interés
compuesto se regresa a cierta cantidad
año tras año
quizás el total de esta cuenta de
efectivo llega a 600 mil dólares al
haberse aplicado los intereses y todo lo
demás a pesar de este hecho aunque se
vea algo tonto quizás de hacer sin
importar este hecho si ustedes fallecen
su familia sólo va a recibir los 500 mil
dólares
y hace que ustedes se pregunten si
ustedes saben que el total de su ahorro
va a ser mayor que la suma asegurada al
momento del fallecimiento lo mejor es
dejar de pagar la prima obtener el
efectivo y dárselo a los familiares en
lugar de esperar a fallecer ya que esto
es malo en dos sentidos primero bueno
ustedes fallecen y en la segunda pues se
obtiene menos dinero así que para
responder a su pregunta en el evento del
fallecimiento la familia no ven nada de
lo que se encuentra en la cuenta de
ahorros solo reciben lo pactado en la
suma asegurada por fallecimiento